[音楽]
ん
今日はねやっぱみんな梅に2と思うよ今日は俺もね友達と海に来るわけなんだけどもう
が海に来ちゃうとまぁ日焼けしちゃうわけなんですよ結構僕焼けやすい体質なんで今年
はまだあほら
首とかもだいぶもう4ぐらいおりとも日焼けしちゃってる感じなんだけどもせっかく海
に来てねこれからガンガン日焼けしてわけなんですけれども暁闇一つ
は特別な音実験的なことをしてみようと思ってるぞ
三宅遅くセンサセグこういうのがありますこの銀色にきれいに焼けるなんていうの
サンタンローションを肌にやさしく焼ができるって言っておりますとすぐせですけどね
これやばいでしょたぶんタンニングウォーターってカナダがねすっごい
なんだのこいこい日焼け恋日焼けができるっていうかれますとこういう日や木を促進
にさせるものがあって利上げしたくない人はポイントを使う
逆に uv カットって fps 50+残すよって全く日焼けしなくなりますこう
いう紫外線をカットして白い肌を保てるやつもあるわけだ
鉄砲ラナー考えついチャットを開けたもっとかっこいいか有田こっちが馬美白的な
きれいな白い肌のダッシュでこっち
鎖骨反面は com 議論ちょっと健康的な夏的なダンスこっち半分半分でこっち側の
折れた骨がもうここでイメージを楽しめるね2つの顔を持つ男に今日はだろうと思い
ますまずはこっちが半分に日焼け止めを塗っていきます
[音楽]
間違いだ
よし ok ですこっち半分は2つ取って代わってもはやでるこっち案内は imalu
と完璧なコーティングがされている多分今回は日焼けしないと思いますじゃあこっちが
あんだろ日焼けしやすいように塗っていきます焼きを乳液
まずからねって言っていきます全然白い
代謝さらにもっと黒くなるように恋引き上げが楽しめるランニング牡丹のこれも塗って
いきます
[音楽]
よっしゃあああ今日聴いた感じは猿とかもわかんないです入って指で一応ですねこっち
が半減が利上げするがはこっちが反面が日焼け止めを塗った河内白と黒が楽しめるよう
になると思いますでは日焼け
行ってきますよ
ああああああ
じゃないですかあああああ
ます
[音楽]
tan
voodoo それが俺
[音楽]
うぇっま
ん